okay so we come to the idea of countable
sets which is a most familiar kind of
infinite sets and a countable set is one
where you can list the elements a 0 a 1
a 2 and so on
so there's a there's a list of all of
the elements of a in which every element
in a appears at some point you can count
up to any given element of a and every
element of a you will eventually get to
you'll be able to count up to it so it's
just a matter of listing it and the
technical definition of a is countable
is if there's a bijection between a and
the non-negative integers because this
list thing in effect really is a mapping
from the non-negative integers to a 0 is
a 0 1 maps to a 1 2 maps to a 2 and
implicitly there's a bisection be
indicated here that's assuming that all
of the A's are distinct for it to be a
by injection so we also have as a
special case the finite sets are also
considered to be countable so really if
n is a but is a bijection to a then a is
called countably infinite the other
possibility is that a is finite and the
two together are just saying a is
countable so what we've just figured out
then from the previous examples is that
the positive integers are countable and
all the integers are countable because
in both cases we exhibited by objections
to the non-negative integers another
important but not very hard example is
the set of finite binary words so we use
this notation 0 1 star meaning all the
finite star means all the finite
sequences of these elements 0 and 1 so
this is just a plane like a binary words
how are they countable well I need a way
to be able to list them in some orderly
way well let's just do it by length
let's begin by twisting the empty word
or string of length 0 and then I'm gonna
list all the 1 bit strings the strings
of length 1 there are two of those so
like the second element the the next
element of the list after the empty
string to be 0 and then the next element
after that b1 then let's list all the
lengths to strengths while there's for
length two binary strings and let's just
list them in some sensible order say by
their binary representation and then I
keep going list the wall the length
three a binary strings there's eight of
those and finally keep going up until
you get to the length in binary strings
of which there are two to the N and this
is a description of a way to list one
after another all of the finite binary
words or finite binary strings and that
listing is implicitly a description of a
by ejection from the non-negative
integers N to the nth element in my
listing and that's a bisection so the
binary words are countable some other
another example of a countable set is
the pairs of non-negative integers so
how can now I got the non-negative
integers I got to find a by actions the
pairs of non-negative integers how am I
gonna do that well it's the same idea as
we used with binary strings there's a
bunch of ways to prove it but but let's
just propagate the binary string idea
let's start listing the pairs of
non-negative integers and after 0 0 I'm
gonna list 2 pairs 0 1 and 1 0 and after
them I'm gonna list 3 pairs 0 2 2 0 & 1
1 and after them 0 3 3 0 1 2 2 1 and if
you can see what I'm doing I'm basically
listing the pairs in the order of the
sum of their coordinates so the ends of
block of pairs that I'm gonna list will
be the pairs whose the sum of whose two
coordinates is n there'll be n plus one
of those and I keep going in this way
this is a nice orderly description of or
a description of a nice orderly way to
list all of the pairs of non-negative
integers within a block invent some
alphabetical rule for for listing the
pairs so I'm gonna I've hinted at a rule
here for listing the finite set of pairs
whose sum is N and you can anyone will
do so that tells us that we have a
projection between the non-negative
integers and
the pairs of non-negative integers so
that's another important bisection now
when you're trying to prove
accountability it's a very useful to
have the following lemma which gives an
alternative characterization
accountability namely a set a is
countable if and only if you can list a
allowing repeats remember our original
definition is that you can list a
without repeats if it's infinite or else
it's finite so there that was the
bisection between the non-negative
integers in a in effect is saying that
that's a listing of all of an infinite
set a with no repeats because it's a
bisection no we're mapping if an element
appeared twice we'd have two different
non-negative integers mapping to it
would break the bisection property the
Injection property and so suppose we
allow repeats and the claim is that
that's fine because you can fix that
so the lemma says that if there's a
surjective function from the
non-negative integers to a then a is
countable well let's just check quickly
in one direction if a is finite then
there's clearly a surjective function
from the non-negative integers to a
there's lots of extra non-negative
integers you don't need just you know if
it's a finite set like ten elements in a
map zero through nine to those ten
elements and map every other
non-negative integer say to the tenth to
the tenth element an element or last
element of a so there's certainly a
surjection of a is finite now suppose
that a is infinite I have a surjection
from the non-negative integers to a so
I'm listening with repeats now I'm
supposed to have a projection if it
matches the other definition how do you
do that well if you're a computer
scientist you know how to change a
sequence with repeats into a sequence
without repeats you just filter it for
duplicates going from left to right take
this infinite sequence of elements of a
in which there are repeats and keep only
the first occurrence of each element
that will define a by injection with the
non-negative integers of a is finite if
a is infinite and that's how we prove
this lemma which I'm just going to
settle for talking through so now we
have another convenient way to show that
a set is countable just by describing
not a byte
put a surjection between the
non-negative integers and a surjections
are often easier to dissin ripe than by
ejections which is why this is a useful
lemma a corollary of this is that if a
set if I'm trying to show that a set a
is countable all that I really need to
do is find some other set that I know to
be countable and describe a surjection
from that other set C to a because I
know that if C is countable then
there'll be a bisection between the
non-negative integers in C and since
when you combine a by injection with a
surjection you wind up with a surjection
that will implicitly define a surjection
from the non-negative integers to a
which match which by the lemma tells me
that a is countable so the general way
to prove something is countable is just
describe a surjection from something you
know to be countable that hits your
target and let's look at an example of
that
um I claim that the rationals are
countable the rational numbers are
countable now this is kind of a little
bit more striking at first because you
know you can see how you can count the
the non-negative integers positive
integers all the integers because
there's a nice sensible way to have one
coming after the other but with the
rationals it's messy in between any two
rationals there's another rational if
there isn't any first rational there
isn't any obvious way to list them all
but really if you stop thinking about
the rationals of how they are laid out
on the real line but just think of them
as pairs of integers then it becomes
clear how to list them because we
already know that the pairs of
non-negative integers are countable so
I'm just gonna map a pair of
non-negative integers MN to the rational
number n divided by n well and might be
0 so if n is 0 just map all of those
pairs to some your favorite rational
number all at 1/2 and that gives us a
nice surjective mapping because every
rational number can be expressed as M
over N least every non-negative rational
number so in effect what we have is a
surjection from the pairs of
non-negative integers which we know is
countable on to the non-negative real
numbers
of rational numbers quotients of
integers which means that the rationals
sure-enough are countable even though
they seem to be spread out all over the
line so again we saw that if and crocin
is countable and there's a search
described above to the non negative
rationals so they're countable well just
looking ahead a little bit it's going to
turn out that in contrast to the
rational numbers the real numbers are
not accountable and in fact neither are
the infinite binary sequences that we
saw there was a bi ejection between the
infinite binary sequences and the
powerset of the non negative integers
and both of these are going to be basic
examples of uncountable sets or sets
that are not countable which we will be
examining in the next lecture